what do you get when you mix the Welsh
Countryside with the Waters of the Irish
sea and seahorses
well apparently some of the best tasting
salt in the entire world
there I was browsing the internet
looking for stories as I often do GBS
did it already did it when I came across
an article that caught my eye and I
thought hmm salt huh since I'm in New
York City I decided to call my friend
Jacob Harrell who some of you might
recognize from this channel to help me
do this story okay thank you Beryl for
that incredibly kind introduction such
lovely words
write the lovely words Jacob is an
award-winning videographer we've worked
together for years at GBS he was the
perfect person to send on this little
journey my name is Jacob Harrell and
we're going to Wales to taste the best
salt in the world
we have no air conditioning it's a long
journey it's very hot
but this salt better be worth it
we're coming for you
[Music]
my name is Jess Lee Wilson my parents
founded the company about 24 years ago
in the area where we are now on Ernest
mourn the Isle of angle seat it's
between 17 and 80 of people our first
language Welsh speakers so the Welsh
language is incredibly important here
which is why my parents when they
started the company called it Helen mon
which is literally anglesea salt in
Welsh they had a pipeline and they paid
the queen for the water that they
extracted from the sea because the queen
actually owns the coastline of the UK so
they did some kind of test batches and
they knew the water was exceptionally
clean because they'd been able to breed
seahorses in the aquarium and seahorses
are notoriously really really fussy so
they thought it's probably going to make
some good salt and they were absolutely
right
Helen monsalt looks feels and tastes
completely different than ordinary table
salt table salt can often be bitter
where this one is not it's flat and
crisp and has a nice crunch when you
bite into it
I'd say the number one thing that really
sets Helen Moon Uncle sea salt a part is
where it's from it's all about how clean
this day is and the process by which we
make it it goes through two natural
filters so it goes through a stun bank
and it goes through a muscle bed and
muscles of one of Nature's greatest sort
of cleaners from there it goes through a
few stages that lead to the final step
each and every single flake is harvested
By Hand by one of our amazing salt
makers it's genuinely quite magic when
you see it because it's really kind of
something coming from nothing people say
oh but salt salt isn't it but the proof
is absolutely in the tasting
[Music]
okay
time to taste
I'm gonna try this standard ordinary
table salt I don't really want
salty bitterness now I'm going to try
hallerman
this is it this is the big moment can
Helen monsalt be better than ordinary
table salt I'm sure it is
how different is it going to be
or that is incredible
there is no bitterness in that at all I
can't describe it it just tastes my mind
is a bit blown about how different salt
can be it makes this seem really fake
and horrible and bitter I've just eaten
a lot of salt in a very short space of
time
so Jacob liked the salt but it could
have just been the fresh Anglesey air
swaying him in One Direction
lucky for me he sent me a few packets to
try myself
I got the package
mini salt so now I'm gonna try it for
myself I'm gonna put it on a classic
American tomato sandwich that is white
bread mayonnaise tomato and salt
what did you all think of the way I cut
my sandwich slightly disturbing right
okay
honestly you can taste the salt and it's
good
I'm just gonna go with a little bit here
salty but it's got like this very clean
flavor it is smooth
whoa I guess Jacob was kind of telling
the truth and he wasn't just Swept Away
With The Winds of the Irish sea
is this the best salt in the world I
haven't tasted all the salts in the
world but this is definitely
definitely a good salt ironically enough
just down the road from Helen mon is
another GBS story that I produce about a
town called plan fire poke Winger
golgaro
and I'm leaving it up here for you to
watch